where the dirt all right Laura Cognito
iron law podcast Lords of gaming dotnet
we're in the building
we have katana zero y'all katana zero in
the building checking it out and we have
one of the one of the great guys in the
realm plan right now who's this fine
who's this fine gentleman playing this
game it's your it's your generic
side-scroller
as far as a genre but they've taken a
story and kind of added to it
you walk the city streets at night and
kind of slash stuff up
let's get that let's get the slashing
looks fantastic
so it's got some RPG elements to it
you're thinking about like what you're
saving these people and I guess that has
an impact really sure
so we got some Harper Eugene little
impact but kept mechanics on my dialogue
choices love the art style very retro
art style
I mean devolver in general they usually
play with games like this and they do a
really good job absolutely
all right here we go we gonna get it in
now we gonna get it in sign of zeros in
the building
let's get our action going on
got the bees jumping
whoa what has happened here
way more oh yeah yeah definitely
saw that influence
so now it's like a replay stage going on
like BCR kind of feel
it is very visceral
okay
see what we know about her abilities
nice nice
are we doing a time warp again
cool platform mechanics
[Music]
nice
clz nice little slow-mo action going on
alright
oh sweet
when you get that going again
there we go
smash dance get that door
how's that control filler we got a pro
controller going on right now for the
switch
see what we're looking for we got this
dog we got this baddie all right looks
like we got someone who got a rescue
he's hurt he's hurtin
looks like is there's like through some
interrupts there's an interrupt phase if
something you could be talking to
somebody well somebody's we're going to
get you really it looks like it but
before that we call yet normally most
games are conversations having
everything kind of pauses yeah like this
doesn't doesn't respect that so we got
escort our guy out nice what's that what
I got
[Laughter]
the Russians are here the resume all
been
there we go
thought we were gonna do in this hole
they come out or they comment it coming
for our girl oh it's going it's going
down
I love all would you mess up the game
says no that won't work
please blow yourself up
that's a different outcome
name is trippy
[Music]
see if we get another outcome here
and loves committing suicide
I snare we go stage clear
[Music]
boys are displeased
seems like want some like secret-agent
kind of bit like backstory
it feels very hotline Miami it's gonna
for samurai feel to it but
they jamming in that apartment that
herbal tea girl
and what if she could do something about
the neighbors
big on the wall keep it down
I wonder what the effects of sleep have
in the game
that looks like a guillotine haha she
got a guillotine in the house exactly
what's she doing
I'm playing the Shadow Realm here sweet
we're in the Shadow Realm hit the shadow
will yo I like her dreams like nine days
for me
but now she'd have therapy sessions
the therapeutic portion of katana zero
[Music]
this game is trippy
we have a new therapy therapeutic
session after the hack in his lashing
[Laughter]
so I'll get it
so just want my drugs it's easy
let's see what how yeah let's wait it
out
which is the boss in the falls okay
it was an hour
[Laughter]
oh well she's getting oh she's getting
that at that medication
gave us best
all right just walks in the office with
a kimono and sword and gets a treatment
that's how it is so I'm assuming this is
probably the next target what you think
mission impossible mission will
self-destruct
our whole set
I'm done I'm done I have good it's a man
it's a bad boy it's called let these
choices are hilarious sit tight
[Music]
washing man she met
you gonna have to hold that
[Music]
all right let's see what more to see
what more stage it is
jams at the jams of rocket
okay
raise the alarm the dragon is here
what's this about
you can like throw these items what's
those items about I don't know trying to
figure that out
okay all right cool go go
we're gonna click on it then we will
rock out a little bit oh yeah oh you do
you look like an adorable item
nice
[Music]
this game is so visceral
you
see we gets us maybe a boss encounter
[Music]
the beats gotta be rockin you're diggin
a fast
[Music]
damnit
nice there you go there you go
doesn't work as a model of life jamming
in the room with it what a hatch
I love how they bobbin what a hat she
didn't move bobble would have had you
yeah you gotta love it nice
0o
nice
I got out and got our cleaver
oh yes
[Music]
if your boy outside nice awesome lasers
there you go
[Music]
yeah they punish you it is at least that
replay mechanic you kind of rock out
nice
I got the gun guy alright here we go oh
yeah this looks very imposing oh you
know it's on easy to smoking he wait for
you
he's gone
no that is brutal
that is so brutal
damn you game developers Wow no
forgiving hey like no you're gonna do
that whole thing over
there you go
I said get out
oh okay
oh oh she's tired because it looks at
Oh
yeah I guess pissing her off had
consequences
nice
it was hilarious
these minimize collateral damage the
future so back to the apartment after a
good day of murdering let's see if it
does it they still in the club next to a
next door the club is still popping